in order to sort of do it right I felt
like it's one thing on stage to play a
character of that size and vehemence and
what one EWTN's character refers to as
the shrill insanity of your mother you
kind of can't under play it and you're
you're you're sort of stuck with that
size of horror and it's from the inside
out you have to commit to it so there's
a lot of smoking and bad posture and
staying up a lot and late and drinking
red wine with Margaux and that all
helped you know I had I would love to
think that I did a lot of things to seem
at one time I looked at Meryl I thought
isn't that odd she laughs just like me
well that's nothing I did that's the way
I laugh so she knew that and we spent
tons of time together lots of time just
just actually socializing and have fun
yeah Tracy you this is the third play
you've adapted for the screen after
killer Joe and bug yes
in order to remake something that's
three hours worth of material into
something that's two hours worth of
material you have to kind of take up the
floorboards a little bit it's it's some
difficult to work you know I think John
and I we approached it thoughtfully in
that we didn't start out by talking
about what
to lose what can we cut we talked about
certainly we wanted to take advantage of
the opportunities that film affordable
that were able to show Osage County and
the play of course we can only suggest
it beyond the walls of the set we
thought it was important that we that we
bring the protagonist and the antagonist
to the foreground and so some things did
have to go and it was they they were
painful decisions some of them my but
but that's the the process and I think
John and I arrived at it together
there's there's a scene between Jean the
daughter and Jonna the Native American
housekeeper it's a long scene in the
play and we did shoot the scene for the
film and unfortunately it seemed to sort
of be a hitch in terms of pace I fought
for it I love the scene it's important
to me but there are other considerations
to be served by the casting of the film
and before I say that I'm wondering if
you know just throw I'm throwing it out
there there the idea of Julia Julianne
and Juliet did that factor in at all at
the cast I made it I had everyone's
pictures up on the wall trying to make
the final decisions and it occurred to
me that that was gonna be very difficult
once we got to the set actually tried
nicknames for a little while that didn't
really work over there didn't but and
then I reverted reverted at one point
you just calling them by their character
names which seemed to work best well
first the the language is beautiful and
beautifully constructed it's very
complicated so the the first standard
was find the best actors that that we
could find for the parts I mean you know
a cast that could actually stand in with
the language with the difficulty of the
material it's not easy material and -
and there was a lot of conversation
about you know how how much does
everyone need to look like each other in
the family but but what became more
important I think was just who was who
were going to be the best actors for the
parts and and knowing who was going to
be in the cast some of the members who
are already going to be here we wanted
to make certain that everyone everyday
could could stand in
and and do the work and and that was a
wonderful process we cast over about six
months and and that there's a dirty
secret which is when you're directing
something the casting process the
auditioning process is a wonderful way
to actually sort of rehearse for
yourself you get all different kinds of
wonderful actors coming in and and and
showing you all these their their their
interpretations of what the material is
which is very useful I knew a bit about
Oklahoma from Colorado and when we got
there I realized that all the places we
were talking about did not look like
what this was going to be and that it
became very important to be there and I
think it was very valuable for the cast
and for everyone we were working on it
to be there we we found a house that we
wanted to use and we actually purchased
the house and it was cheaper than
building a single set it was with with
fifty acres and we were right in Osage
County we're really in the place so the
images were there the language was there
we spent time around people from from
there got to know them and and I think
it infuses the whole film with a sense
of place which is which is very
important
I love I saw this on stage on Broadway
five years ago and it blew me away and
when I read the script the same thing
happened all over again and I felt like
I understood who she was I didn't mean
to have her not be pitied or sympathized
with but I felt like she had a very
noble life actually in a life that many
people choose and then want something
different and I really cared about her
and she it wasn't her plan to stay
behind everybody else left and so
somebody had to stay at that point and
and then that meant she had enough it
was time to go I was playing the put
together gal focused on her appearance
and it's not really something I
naturally gravitates heard in characters
so I actually relished the fact that I
was playing a girl that gets her hair
you know does her hair and has to leave
the house with a lip on as my mother
would say
put your lip on but this um was
thrilling for me when I first read that
three-page monologue there's so many
things about Karen it's just that we've
met you I've met the person that talks
incessantly and is positive incessantly
and what is that masking and this role
came at a very strange time in my life I
was dealing with the possible I have my
dad had had a heart attack and he's
still here thank God but but I was
losing the ability to make life rosy at
that time so to look at a character who
that's her survival is that it's really
gonna be great it's great it's great you
know I I was like uh you know if I could
only have that delusion in my life right
now and make things great but I had lost
the ability to to have faith or these
things so you know I've since regained
it but um when I read the sides to
audition with for gene it was one of
those things where I kind of just like
felt really attached to her immediately
which was really bizarre for me and I
guess it's because I I felt like I knew
somebody just like it and so I felt like
it helped but I had also kind of
remembered that like way back three
years ago when I was 14 that she's just
trying to be really tough because and
not care about anything because it's a
lot easier than like showing that you're
actually really upset about things and
really vulnerable so like I would when I
was 14 to I was like and 15 I was like
nothing bothers me I'm great like it's
fine like whatever I don't even care and
it kind of is easier and then she finds
herself in this situation and I think
that sometimes you can get yourself into
really really bad dangerous situations
and not like you don't even realize that
at all and then when you do kind of step
back from it it's like oh yeah like that
and that's like what John really helped
me with Chu in that scene was that she
kind of pulls away from it and everybody
comes out and then she kind of realizes
that like oh this is really good and
this is sketchy as hell so yeah and but
that's what I really liked about her the
one thing that you know people have fun
with with with Steve and it always feels
wrong you know I always wanted to honor
how dangerous a person he was and then
forget it and be the person that he is
which is as far as Karen is concerned
it's the love of her life I'm a
dedicated well now fourth husband but
who's to say that doesn't mean this is
the one for me so I it was interesting I
worked extensively with John and then
Abigail and I worked together on her own
actually her mother was there as well
which was really helpful in all honesty
it was and so of course what we had to
work on was smoking a joint like that
where you put the lid end in your mouth
so this is someone no one here knows on
the we we you know we rehearsed it the
night before and then we shot it and by
the end of that second day I had
blisters all over in my mouth because I
had burned it because that's hot for hay
but how great is that moment when you
have that shocking reveal you think you
hear it it's on the stairs that was
always written this way and Tracy's play
of course that all took place in front
of you on stage and you saw the whole
thing play so part of me I even risked
saying to John can we you know put some
of that on screen but it's so satisfying
to wonder and then worried and then see
the very thing that you that you hate
and obviously men like this are far too
common and I just make sure that said
because Tracy's trick of course is to
make him really kind of charming and
almost feel like he would
helped save the the troubles a little
bit we haven't talked about the dinner
scene yet it comes Merrill to the to the
head of the dinner table and we're I to
I and think maybe this might be a might
be a nice dinner and it was an 18-page
scene broke it up into six pages roughly
six pages per day I think it at each
take something comes at us something is
is given to us a little differently and
we we won't look to stay fresh to you
know respond because we don't know
what's coming at us everything
everything is is especially Merrill has
the bulk of the lines and all and and
she she keeps us on our toes because she
gives us she gives us a a comic take a
brutal take a nasty take a drug-addled
take and a combination of all that you
know so I think everybody realizes our
was some very tectal yeah